Tehát ugyanúgy mentem dolgozni,
találkoztam a barátaimmal, de egy adott
ponton már csak azért keltem fel, hogy
megvegyem a cuccot. Ühüm. Szóval onnan
és ha nem volt, akkor meg nagyon mély
alkoholizmusba zuhantam. Tehát hogy ez
így is, úgy is kerestem valamit, amivel
kompenzálom. Bár ilyenkor valami
mozgatott téged. Igen. Tehát a célodat a
cél megvolt. Igen. Csak a kérdés az,
hogy ki tűzi ki ezt a célt? Tehát az
szertőzik ki a célt számodra és használ
téged, mint egy, mint egy báb, amelyik
visz ide is így. Te ilyen marionett
bábú, vagy pedig vagy pedig te
önmagadnak a az ura akarsz lenni, és és
lehetünk-e önmagunk urral. Tehát ez egy
fontos kérdés. Egy darabig, egy darabig,
de aztán beszippant, és nem nem már
mondom, tehát amikor már úgy kelsz fel,
hogy hogy az az egy célom van, hogy
belőjem magam, vagy éppen megigyok egy
liter whiskit, tehát
hogy és eljut hamar odáig az ember.